- C'est l'été, il fait chaud.
Les gens apprécient le soleil,
- On vient s'amuser,
il fait beau, on eprprofite!
- Moi, je pense pas que les gens
font tellement attention, non.
- Le Q s s s s s s s s s s s s ,
les moyennes hebdomadaires
des nouveaux cas de COVID-19
ont doublé depuis le mois
de juin. Malgré cela,
des mesureadadditionnelles.
- Non, plus maintenant, non.néne
qu'à umomoment donné, il faut
avancer, il ne faut pas reculert
enco l les mêmes, ça n'a pas
changé. Donc, non, on ne change.
PoPour cet immunologiste,
la santé publique envoieun messe
en appelant à la vigilance
sans ajouter de mesures.
Dr ANDRÉ VEILLETTE, immunologue
Inst. recherches cliniques Mtl
- C'est clair que les messages
sont pas clairs. Je pense
l'impression que la pandémie
est prquque terminée.
- Mais elle est loin d'être
affaiblie. Ailleurs au Canada,
la pandémie reprend de
de l'Atlantique voient
leurs nouveaux cas augmeerer
en flèche.
- C'est inquiétant.
puis je suis les règlements,
mais on est vaccésés. Puis s'ils
demandent d'autres règlements,
on va les suivre.
plusieurs à revoir leurs plans
de vacans.s.
- Oui, les plans de vacances
ont changé parce que la COVID,
Et comme vous nous voyez, nous,
onon a nos masques. On continue
les mêmes habitudes.
- Au Québec, l'incompréhensiones
de maladie semble favoriser
la propagation du virus.
Dr LUC BOILEAU, directeur
national de santé publiq ç ç ç e
contamine tant, c'est parce que
les gens ne respectent pas
cette règle de 10 jours.
C'est ce qui fçaçaçaçaçaçaçaçaç.
- Sur le site web du
gouvernement, il est inscrit
que l'isolement doit durer cinq
jours
reprendre après cette période
à condition de porter le masque
durant un autre cinq jours.
- Mais définitivement,
c'est pas assez. Alors après
cinq jours, il y a beaucoup
gens qui ont encore des tests
rapides positifs, il y a
encore du virus.
- Le ministre Christn n Dubé
souhaite responsabiliser les
Québécois face à cette nouvelle
d'imposer de nouvelles mesures
en plein été, à quelques
semaines d'une campagne
électorale.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau,
Radio-Canada, Montréal